let's go to our caller from the 905 area
code crazy day on the phones today 905
you're up next
hey David this is a Nick from Texas
go ahead Nick and my question was um
what do you think about the primary
Democratic turnout or the primary voter
turnout for the Democrats you know young
they said Texas Oklahoma California
there's been dramatic increases in voter
turnout from the Democrats yep yeah bill
scher spoke to us about this earlier in
the week and he has pointed out that we
should all be very cautious about
assuming that there's gonna be a blue
wave in November but that if there is
one indicator that things could go well
for Democrats it's that the primary
turnout for Democrats so far has been
good not in every single place but in a
lot of places so listen you know Nick
you can find information you can find
data to support an upcoming blue wave
you can find data to support a waning
level of enthusiasm I think what we need
to do is not assume anything and every
single person needs to go out and vote
in November that's the only way forward
because we just we can look at any
indicator and primary turnout is one of
them we just need to be abundantly sure
that every vote that is a possible vote
becomes a real vote yeah I'm not yeah
I'm not really assuming that there's an
ax be a blue wave but just based off of
some of the you know the states that
I've been looking at for the primaries
of Democratic turnout is definitely
higher yes and in some places even
though you know 100 percent maybe
percent thirty percent so how would you
smile good alright well thank you
appreciate the call and you're
absolutely right
Democratic voter turnout is it is up in
those places